lifeline is an advice show for
entertainment purposes only if you need
real help or advice please seek a
therapist or a licensed professional
[Music]
hello
[Music]
you think about how this is the fourth
episode this is the fourth episode you
know that though it feels like well if i
think about it i know that but i off
like the top of my head
it feels like we've been doing it for a
long time really yeah
maybe you're just in your element dude
i'm feeling it i'm in the [ __ ] zone
wow yep um
so
how do you feel about the fact that we
haven't eaten burritos beforehand
better
i feel less ecstatic no no no no i do
yeah don't tell me no don't ask a
question because you're just going to
formatively you just say no i don't like
that you're going against me just to go
against me right getting off on the
wrong foot um
why are you doing this
i'll tell you why i'm doing that cool
but i'm pissed that you pointed it well
because you did it two or three times
people can think you have tourettes
so i'm pissed that you pointed it out no
it's better to be honest let's get it
out in the open ah i'm doing it because
there's a thing going on
there we go i fixed it it's attached
this there's a hood in it
so it doesn't
go down like most collars like there's
no way to put it down it only stays like
that oh because there's like something
bunched up in here okay
and sometimes my hair which is
like
voluptuous and long yeah uh gets stuck
on it and i to do a quick thing i go i
go well i don't remember what i did that
whatever that is [ __ ] absolutely
terrible i think it's great well it's
not dude
do you do it walking around
do i do it walking around like this no
no because it doesn't matter
it's not good dude uh
i think it's all right yo uh i got a new
tattoo oh you did yeah let me see it you
haven't seen it i didn't even see it no
uh whoa that that's really good yeah
it's a triceratops uh skull i mean i
know what it is calvin likes it oh does
he try to like take it off you
okay well
trying to [ __ ] look buff look at do
it at a bodybuilding show look at how i
look at it so [ __ ] but it's a
triceratops skull and it's gr and i love
it and uh that's their best tattoo that
you think so i mean
certainly in terms of like i think he's
like the artistry he's [ __ ] good yeah
he's really really great devin menna at
uh what's it called um
uh some vatican vatican studios
in irvine
and it's uh and it's great and i love it
and it's peeling so when it gets regular
and then the [ __ ] hair grows back in
you could imagine how [ __ ] crazy good
i'll look right now because i always
need it on the other side right because
i had the [ __ ] over here like this and
now i have the [ __ ] over here like this
and when i'm like this dude now i look
like a full [ __ ] tattered dude i'm
going to be tied up you are
a dude you think i'm a tatted dude would
you say i'm like a tied it up dude
you have a tattoo on your neck and all
over your arms and on your chest how
many tattoos do you think it takes to be
a tattoo one dude two three four five
five i have six i don't like that you're
acting like you don't know how many
tattoos you have i don't okay well then
that's the mark of the chatted dog yeah
fair enough fair enough yes if you don't
know how many you have i'm sexy dude
don't that's what you're saying don't i
don't like when people act like they're
not flexing they're just doing a normal
thing but they're actually flexible but
i was i wasn't yeah yeah but i'm i'm not
pretending like i'm not flexing i am
flexing and i know it and everyone knows
that and that's why i know it
um so i got this tattoo and it's great
and it's flaking and can you imagine
when it looks not flaking and the hair
pops back in like how good i'm gonna
look i can completely imagine that now
on the other hand now on the other hand
who the [ __ ] grows hair on the inside of
their arms well no but here's the thing
because they shave it a little bit yeah
and there's no hair there but there's no
hair there because they [ __ ] shave it
in general i know but you see how
there's hair over here oh a little baby
so there'll be a little hair over here
and it'll cover it up nicely a little
bit and it'll look like i've had it for
a while because also it's very dark
because i just got it it needs to fade a
little bit so it looks like you know so
i look like i've been through some [ __ ]
because right now it looks like i'm just
like a fresh tatted up dude and you
don't want to look like a fresh tatted
up dude that's kind of because it's like
oh you just got that people like you
just got that dude i was walking around
this for for two weeks i couldn't do
anything people like oh you just got
that and it made me feel like [ __ ]
just gotten things i mean i don't know
it makes me i don't want people to i i
don't want to like talk about it like if
you're like oh when'd you get that oh
yeah i got a long time ago that's cool
but if it's like oh you just got that
yeah where oh i got it at this place oh
yeah he did my brother or i know about
him from instagram and then i gotta
[ __ ] sit there and i'm just like
actually just let me get three shots of
coffee you should prepare for that if
you're gonna get a tattoo a big one on
your [ __ ] neck you know what i saw i
saw a lady today today as i was getting
these [ __ ] three shots over over ice
i only got three because i went to get
four and the lady said uh okay let me
get four shots i said let me get four
shots of espresso and she said okay
and she was doing it
and then she was like wait hold on and
i'm already like okay and she was like
hold on wait i can't okay all right now
i have it go through and then i put the
credit card and i did it and it went
boop and she goes oh wait hold on
um and then i and then she looked at me
and she was like okay i i go to the
bathroom and come back and then you'll
and then we'll take care of it so i went
to the bathroom and i came back because
i had to go without knocking she wasn't
just like being like
a [ __ ] a weird thing to say but then she
was like go to the bathroom
and uh and so i i came back after my
bathroom and she said it all worked out
and then i and then the lady goes chris
and i and i get it and she goes boom and
just for shits i was like how many shots
is in there and she said three
okay i ordered four oh so everything was
[ __ ] up but so i was there and i saw
as i was doing this because i was
looking around because nothing was going
right and i was there for too long i
looked around and i saw a lady with a
shirt that said don't talk to me
and you didn't like that no i didn't
like it at first because it's like so
rude
but it's not personal right but then
it's like if i had that shirt
people would maybe not talk to me about
that kind of [ __ ] is what i'm saying
here's why i don't like it well i don't
like it
but go ahead i it presumes people want
to talk to you yeah it's annoying it is
a little but it's so presumptuous i know
i want to go up to that person and say i
want to [ __ ] talk to you anyway yeah
i specifically do not want to talk to
you but your shitty shirt made me come
talk to you i would say that that shirt
probably makes more people talk to you
than not yes and that's definitely true
yeah do you think she sees people do you
think she sees people come out tour and
go like this
and walk away yeah probably yeah
yeah um probably not but um
i don't know man i need to get some sort
of [ __ ] thing because people are
obviously always coming up and talking
to me and [ __ ] and usually it's nice
there was a uh chris you remember
brittany mcdonald in like fourth fifth
grade
she wore a shirt that and she was like
one of the only girls
with this was young girls yeah okay like
with the only girls with like about an
actual grown in body yet and
over and you talk to her and you're
actually having a conversation around
she goes like this check it
right right
up up right and then i read up you need
to read
you need to get a shirt that says my
dicks down here okay with an arrow
everyone knows that though just i'm just
saying but you know where people's eyes
are too they're not looking at anyone's
what if you got it sure what if you got
a hat that said my eyes are down here
i think the issue would be that it
wouldn't make any sense because no one's
looking at it i know i know but that's a
good thing to like make fun of shirts
like oh so you get a hat that says my
eyes are down here a shirt that says my
eyes are up here my pants that say you
get pants to say my eyes are way up
there just pants that are telling you
where the eyes are
all of your clothes directing you to the
eyes and then a jacket with on the back
it says my eyes are on the other side
above this
yeah okay cool merch that could work um
now let me tell you what i'm insecure
about producer chris said put left a
note from me said don't touch the
microphone now i keep thinking about not
touching it not touching it am i going
to touch it how am i going to touch it
if i want to move it that will catch it
that's okay but i just did but don't be
ginger like that gingerly you look like
a [ __ ] [ __ ] well relax you sound so
hateful
yeah you sound so hateful when you're
that's what i'm trying to illustrate
like this just go like this handle it
bro handle it but don't touch this
what's that about oh
oh this is not this jerking a guy this
is jerking that guy off like this dude
imagine you know how something yeah when
you imagine doing it without the actual
instrument like
yeah yeah yeah yeah i know i know but
you're like you didn't know you were
like this i don't like so hold on let me
get this over here let me get this over
here this was good look how you taught
me yeah that's so obvious that it does
that okay but anyway don't say it like
anyway it doesn't matter but um so i got
a new tattoo i was at the coffee shop
they got me the wrong order i got the
three shots and also the lady had the
shirt and that was my day and and that
was great so
you're welcome for telling you that
um should we get into the episode of
lifeline it's the fourth episode of
lifeline and we've got some bangers
today rob that's what that's what chris
said crystal producer over there so now
if they're not bangers you know whose
fault it is he said they're bangers so
let's do this
hey what up delia brothers love you guys
love the new show uh i had a situation
come up that i felt i could get your
advice on uh and it has to do with the
intention behind a joke that you make to
your friend
versus the way that it lands the impact
and how much of that impact are you
responsible for when you know it's
coming from a good place
so i had this friend come over
she walked into our kitchen first time
i've seen her in years and she's wearing
this big beautiful flowy dress and so as
i hugged her to greet her i hit her with
the hills are alive with the sound of
music
uh anyway i thought the hang went great
couple days later she hits me with a
text demanding an apology
for mocking her
and um
immediately i flew into a defensive mode
saying like hey that was from a place of
love i was so happy to see you i would
never
intentionally like mock you to make you
feel bad and she wouldn't relent
demanded an apology and so i apologized
i'm sorry but when you apologize for
something like that i think it takes
something away from you i i really
struggled living in the moment for a
second uh you know typically i trust
that i love my friends and so jokes are
coming from a place of love and all said
i was second guessing myself life didn't
rip quite as hard it was it was more
like a tear life tore and i need it to
rip you know what i'm saying
so
i guess i just want your advice would
you apologize in those circumstances
that's
very specific
because
but in general would you apologize if
someone took offense would i guess the
quest that's the example yeah but
specifically if someone took offense to
a joke that you made that you knew
was not mean-spirited which that
definitely was not no no i thought he
was going to be like hey you're fat well
that would be yeah obviously
yeah but
uh i i don't i mean i would just be like
you you you're a well here's what i
would have been
i mean
this is so weird because if you're that
good of a friend with somebody yeah you
should know
what kind of temperament they have with
stuff like that yeah and it's really odd
to hit them with something like that and
then be so blindsided i'm not saying
that this guy is wrong in any way but
like
it's just odd that he didn't know that
or maybe she's going through some [ __ ]
you're saying know your audience better
know your audience but but but it it
that's so benign that seems so so
awkward so i don't i don't really
understand that's why i'm that's why i'm
hesit that's why i'm i think maybe she's
going through something maybe her family
was murdered when the sound of music was
playing yeah just like the hills are
alive and she walks in and the
soundtrack's playing and her family's
just like hanging right right right
right um
i don't i don't know i i don't i don't
understand that this is it's so
confusing to me because it was benign
but i you know it then it depends on
what the friendship is worth right like
if the friendship is worth like there's
there's a difference between saying i'm
sorry for what i did and then saying oh
i'm sorry you're offended yeah we're
right i think that this calls for one of
those situations i'm sorry you're
offended yeah i'm i'm sorry you're
offended but i completely i'm sorry i
offended you was better okay i'm sorry i
offended you yeah right but this was a
complete joke right also the sound of
music [ __ ] rips yeah right you know
what i mean like it's one of my favorite
musicals how do you know how i feel
about this you could be like yo yo hold
on you're assuming that i think that the
sound of music is right yeah
dude and then be like wes you know what
i mean or because you don't want me to
do
[ __ ] spin move right or just prove
you love sounding music and sing more
songs yeah music yeah be like oh how
much do you know the sound of the music
sound of the music yeah how do you know
much sound of your music i mean right
forgot how to speak and then the girl's
like well i don't i know the hills are
alive and from sound of the music and
then you go oh yeah well check this out
and you do the whole [ __ ] [ __ ] no
matter what she's doing from a to z you
do the whole [ __ ] soundtrack she
tries to leave getting her car you get
in the car with her and you're still
singing yeah and then when you're done
you go like this oh so that's how much i
know about the sound of music and guess
what sound of music [ __ ] rips i love
sound of music what i'm saying is when i
hug you and sing that is i love you did
you know that no oh you didn't right
couples have a ride home and then yeah
and then you can be offended as well
yeah but i do think that there's a big
difference between i'm sorry
you're offended which is like nothing
kind of that's kind of like a [ __ ]
thing to say it's it's okay to say i'm
sorry if i offend i'm sorry i'm sorry
that i offended you is an okay apology
i'm sorry you're offended is nothing
it's just like i'm sorry at the way
you're made up yeah yeah like think
about this if you [ __ ] on someone right
and you thought it was funny okay but
i'm just not ever it's not ever funny
but if someone's sleeping and you [ __ ]
on their neck
okay and then they wake up and they're
like oh my god there's [ __ ] all over my
neck what the [ __ ] paul or whatever his
name is you know he'd come in and paul
comes in like this right you know what i
mean yeah and he's like did you [ __ ] on
my neck and i was like isn't that
[ __ ] hilarious right like no i demand
an apology yeah it's like saying
i'm sorry you got [ __ ] on
yeah it is that's exactly right though
that's exactly because it was you dude
that's why
i'm sorry i [ __ ] on you
you should always say that if you [ __ ]
on somebody yeah but i'm saying it's
it's not like saying
i apologize
that i [ __ ] on you it's like saying
i'm sorry you got [ __ ] on by me yeah
you're taking no responsibility right
now here's the other thing though if you
ins if you demand an apology from
a friend for a joke that you made yeah
you're [ __ ] a weirdo yeah
so
a good that you i think apologize i
don't think you should think about it
like it took something out of you like
the it's it's on the other person for
being that offended for demanding an
apology about a sound a music joke right
[ __ ] ease up dude yeah that is a
[ __ ] weird thing to imagine how she
responds to things that are actually
offensive right right she's challenging
you to a duel a sword fight
you know what i mean like what the [ __ ]
yeah how how bad is it when you really
like pull out the big guns on an actual
insult
does she just like crumble or like
use violence like what are the you got
to think about like the levels of
offense here yeah true oh you know what
she is probably some [ __ ] super woke
person right gotta be gotta be but
that's not even that though i know it's
not but i'm sensing things and what we
do is we sense things on this podcast
okay i didn't realize that was one of
the things that you did probably a woke
person and okay i'm sensing another
thing that this guy's a good guy like
he's obviously a good guy because he's
thinking about he's a good guy right
yeah he's a good guy um
and and the fact that she's not thinking
about it she's like no i demand an
apology period
i think she's a good guy too she's just
got some [ __ ] going on that's right
everyone's a good guy struck a chord
something struck a chord and i think
yeah take the loss whatever apologize
whatever let it go but like that is a
[ __ ] weird thing to be all up in arms
about yeah i love the sound of music
what are you talking about yeah
yeah that's so weird that's not
offensive at all not at all we figured
it out for that guy yep and don't really
kind of probably don't really be friends
with that person that's oh yeah you got
it because you got to be so careful i
know you got to be so careful
you should just be walking around like
this around that person all the time and
they would say what are you doing to be
like well i got to do this because i got
a tiptoe around you obviously because
you got so offended by a [ __ ] musical
that i love and the passive aggressive
do a spin move and go back okay let's
spin move again piss me off but okay all
right let's go to the next
hi guys um we see so many fans like
literal fans um
i
am a recovering drug addict from
very hard drugs deadly drugs and
i
[Music]
have been smoking weed for two or three
months now
after
over a year of sobriety
um my private therapist was actually my
therapist in rehab
and the rule was for her to be my
private therapist i had to be sober so i
haven't told her that i've been smoking
weed
in fear that she won't be my therapist
anymore
um a lot of people in
n a and a a will tell you that if you do
smoke weed or do anything mind altering
you will resort back to your drug of
choice eventually which isn't isn't even
a thought in my mind um because i know
it will kill me so
my question is do i tell her or do i not
tell her thanks guys
uh
there's a few parts to that i think and
i think one is if you have a therapist
you got to tell them yeah because
they're that's what they're there for
but also
i i'm no [ __ ] expert
but i do truly believe that weed is not
a gateway wow two other drugs that are
going to kill you that's my that's a
high intake i'm not actually an expert i
feel kind of like i don't even want to
give that advice yeah that's my feeling
because i don't want people to be like
well matt said it and wind up on a
gurney right exactly that's not what i
want i don't want that at all that's you
don't want to lay people horizontal just
because of your [ __ ] advice but i've
always thought that was weird i know
plenty of sober people oops a horizontal
you know what i mean about oops did you
keep talking over me okay great okay so
you know what i mean about oops and i'm
gonna keep going right yeah okay so i
think that you the i've always been
surprised when sober people say that
they can't smoke weed
but they can't that's part of their
[ __ ] program you're not an addict
though yeah okay but still it surprises
me because i know a lot about weed if
you know what i mean right uh you sell
it and it's
[Laughter]
so stupid
it's just it's just
i've always thought of weed is extremely
harmless uh i don't see it as any kind
of gateway that being said you do
you do have to tell your therapist yeah
you can't have a relationship with your
therapist or you're like i tell them
ninety percent of [ __ ] but i don't tell
them 100 issues
there's no point of having a therapist
if you're not going to tell them the
entire truth especially if they're your
therapist from rehab you don't want to
hide that [ __ ] from the therapist okay
so i think and here we go i think
there's something weird going on here
okay first of all i don't know how
normal it is for your therapist in rehab
to be your therapist after rehab i don't
know it might be normal but i've
actually never heard that actually i've
never heard that so number one that's
kind of that could be like a pink flag
you know what i mean like almost red
okay and there's another thing here
where a therapist
shouldn't be
say i believe i don't know if this is
true or not but i i'm pretty sure that a
therapist shouldn't be like well if you
do this i'm not going to be your
therapist anymore that's true yeah
you're not going to lose the therapist
you can't but but but that's what the
therapist is saying the therapist is
saying if you do
i'll only be your therapist
if you stay sober so if she doesn't say
sober that what she's saying is what
she's saying her therapist says you're
right i can't be your therapist and you
that's a bad thing that's not right to
do that yeah is to be like if you do
this i'm not
gonna be your therapist anymore because
that just sets her up to [ __ ] lie
yeah that's true yeah yes got into that
one dude i'm making it about you no but
i should be have a [ __ ] phd in this
[ __ ] sometimes you say i got out of that
one and you weren't in it i wasn't in a
thing dude so you need therapy i know
but what i'm saying is her and i got
into that one yes we got into that one
dude
but that's the thing is
that's a very odd [ __ ] thing to say
as a therapist hey just so you know
we're in ovaries or overeaters anonymous
okay and i'm your therapist for
overeaters anonymous yeah and now that's
so hard to say because no matter what i
do when i say it i [ __ ] it up right
reader's anonymous you did it
okay okay so
hey i'm your overeaters anonymous
therapist yeah check it out you eat
doughnuts
we can't talk no more that's [ __ ] it
defeats the purpose you're gonna be
first of all you're gonna be like oh
[ __ ] i'm scared i don't wanna [ __ ] up
and i can't tell them if i do second of
all that makes me wanna [ __ ] hightail
it to windchill sure yeah because it's
like no no no but when an addict thinks
no no no they go secretly i could
probably get around that right trust me
baby i'm an addict right you know and so
this is a thing it may not be a gateway
drug in the fact that when i get high it
wants me to i want to get more high on
other [ __ ] yeah but you're still doing
the illicit behavior that's going to
lead to more illicit behavior maybe
right but but you know and i know your
argument is oh weed isn't a gateway drug
hey you drink coffee that's caffeine
that's a gateway drug and if you [ __ ]
do it that way every drug is a gateway
drug right it's nicotine a lot of sure
smoke right yeah but um but yeah i don't
know dude the the gateway here is lying
the egg right here is lying
you're compartmentalizing your life and
you're compartmentalizing your behavior
and think and you're well some people
say it's not a gateway drug that's a
slippery slope dude that's when the
[ __ ] boulder is just a snowball at
the top of the hill oh my god and guess
what happens when it gets lower it gets
bigger and bigger and out of control and
it knocks down everything in your path
so secretly talking about me
truth though dude that is
so you got to be honest with your
therapist and if they're not going to be
your therapist anymore then either get
back into rehab or
get a new therapist get a new therapist
yeah
yeah
yeah
okay you good yeah i mean i got into a
little bit of preacher mode that was
good that was good i don't have anything
more to add to that yeah okay all right
who
wants
better a sex i do oh okay great do you
all you [ __ ] should because the sexy
oven isn't as good as it could be the
best way to get started on having great
[ __ ] sex is to go to adam and eve.com
right now i mean eve is offering 50 off
just about everything wow it's like
they're giving it away plus free
shipping right was just gonna say it
plus free shipping but more than that
well they want to make your life easy i
was gonna say this yeah they want to
make your life easy they offer discreet
shipping as your privacy is their
priority it's not even gonna say who
it's [ __ ] for you that that means if
you get a box of something it's not
gonna be like dildos in here yes exactly
some butt plugs in here and that's
uh free shipping on your entire order
what do they have like crazy sex toys
they have male sex toys they got
vibrators they got [ __ ] rings they got
lubes they got bath and body stuff wow
they got bondage stuff they got dildos
they got [ __ ] butt plus sounds like
now is the time to try something new
right yeah they got penis pumps that
doesn't matter how much you
you spend or what you buy it'll be
packaged and sent discreetly for free
more pleasure and satisfaction in your
bedroom go to adamandeve.com select any
item any one item it could be an
adventurous new toy or something you
desire uh that's uh anything anything
desired just enter offer code lifeline
at checkout and you'll get 50 off almost
any item adamandeve.com right now and
when you do you'll also get free
shipping on your entire order when you
enter offer code lifeline that's
lifeline l-i-f-e-l-i-n-e
adamandeve.com this is exclusive and
it's an offer specific to this podcast
exclusively for this podcast so be sure
to use this code lifeline to get
you
not just the discount but also the 100
free shipping code lifeline [ __ ] yeah
get that [ __ ] and get it quick get it
now improve your sex life now
good luck by the way good luck man and
fight the good fight we got a ghost
oh i've been haunting too many people
i'm unsure if i should haunt all races
what do you think about haunting blacks
wow okay
oh hi madame chris my name is marlon
pause that show
really hope
isis um all right cool yeah is it okay
to be had all different races um
okay okay go ahead it's a pissed oh
cause he's kkk oh hi madame chris my
name is marlon i really love the show i
really hope you could also get your dad
on for a special epis episode maybe
10.
uh look i've got a girlfriend we've been
together two years we love each other a
lot i killed him we want to spend the
rest of our lives together the one thing
we don't match up on is our sex drive
mine's a lot higher than hers yeah we
talk about it a lot and we've accepted
that that's just something different
between us uh we do have sex like once
every
week or once every two weeks but
i'm wondering if
my libido will eventually drop and match
hers or will it continue to be a problem
should i seek out other options or
just try and deal with it i mean for
reference we're in our early 30s
thanks guys
bro he had a [ __ ]
towel on his head
hey guy
right
[Applause]
it wasn't really the optimal way to do
that but also you started talking like
dude that was [ __ ] hilarious dude i
mean he had a [ __ ] towel on i think
he put a thing on his voice didn't he no
no dude he definitely just talked like
this and he was so hot under there you
know well yeah he was so hot and sweaty
dude also um you know
uh
you wanted you want to [ __ ] more and she
doesn't well first of all he said should
i explore other alternatives
no well well well like what though porn
that's different i mean
like rub some out throughout the week to
like even yourself out and get on her
left and sure if you do you have to
clean up right there because you have a
towel but if you mean other options
cheating on her [ __ ] no right no no
don't don't cheat on her but that's he
left it open i'm thinking he's thinking
about slipping and you should not slip
okay don't you need to do that break up
with her that's a valid reason to break
up somebody true hey we don't [ __ ]
enough sweetheart gotta go and then go
you know doing someone else and then
good for you you also have a [ __ ]
towel to clean it up later right right
okay but um
yeah uh she
okay i always say this foreplay is
everything until you have sex meaning
not just in the bed meaning before that
so maybe focus on your partner as much
as you possibly can
because then everything's clean on your
side right i'm doing all i can you walk
up to say look sweetheart i'm doing all
i can you say to her [ __ ]
i'm doing all i can in this relationship
and you don't want to have sex with me
and i don't know what to do and it's not
[ __ ] working right right and you
leave what if his girlfriend was in the
background she had a towel on her head
too they might that's just how i would
they might he might not even be
disguised
yeah yeah yeah true so um
man i don't know by the way that was me
i don't know i don't know i think that
you this is the age-old struggle you
know obviously you want to [ __ ] more
because
you know you're the guy and she's the
girl and then obviously she doesn't want
to [ __ ] as much because you're the kind
of guy that wears a towel and [ __ ]
sends a video to us right actually
because that's not sexy i think that's a
that's
a common myth that is actually not true
girls don't like to join as much as guys
my experience yeah
i mean that's not
talk to a lot of women who've been
unhappy with the amount but women say
[ __ ] wants to
they say [ __ ] like let's fix up an old
car but they don't mean but that has
now you're pissing me off why because
that has absolutely nothing to do with
anything yeah and men also just say [ __ ]
i know that so my point is women in my
experience have talked about they
don't have enough sex and they want to
have more sex but their partner their
male partner tends to want to have more
sex in the beginning
and the woman wants to have more sex
later and the guy's like i'm tired of it
so but anyway this is the classic
typical common [ __ ] complaint but
all you can do is meet her at her place
you can't make her have sex with you
more because she doesn't want to and if
someone man or woman doesn't want to be
having sex it sucks to be the person
that's like can't we have it more yeah
it's so unsexy that sucks it's so unsexy
and then you have to think about how
you're making the other person have sex
with you and that sucks too
yeah because when you're like if you
come in first of all it's not good for
anybody if you're working hey do you
think maybe we could have sex more
because you are like oh i'm a [ __ ] i'm
not a man about it and then she's like
what's this [ __ ] punk ass doing
you're so insecure bad for everybody so
you know what you got to do dude get
your confidence up take that towel off
you know what you should do you should
have [ __ ] sent in the video with your
face and been like all right here's
what's going on my chick won't do this
my chick won't do that i mean he's
probably doing it for anonymity reasons
because of his chick but i'm saying
don't be bashful walk in that spin move
mentality is what you need to have
[ __ ] damn it man you don't need to do
a spin move but if that's a mentality
i'm talking about the spin move
mentality right and you got to [ __ ]
go in with that spin move mentality and
walk up maybe get a new way to walk but
like figure out it's your real way to
walk do you have a towel on your head
when you do this or you don't have no
you don't have it bro it's all you and
you walk in and you're like sweetheart
we're going to [ __ ] botanical gardens
or something and then you go there and
you think sex the whole time right okay
and you do everything you can you get
her flowers you make her feel romantic
right because maybe this guy's thinking
about how oh i'm the [ __ ] i'm i'm
working out i'm being sexy but you're
not being sexy in the way that she wants
to be she thinks that you should be sexy
right
foreplay is everything up until the
bedroom right okay and then [ __ ]
there's a book that my therapist says i
should read that i didn't read but she's
like in the book the guy says that you
need to do everything you can always to
try and uh
uh
everything for your partner that's the
only way a relationship works is if you
do everything for your partner and it's
always on your mind because
then they're going to feel wanted and
appreciated yeah but what what are you
saying that you're you're saying if you
think of everything as foreplay you're
constantly leading up to having sex yes
so only twice a week might be okay for
you no i'm saying she'll want to have it
more oh really yeah because you're being
romantic and [ __ ] i don't know you're
being romantic in your life i mean but
here's the thing what if that doesn't
pan out for him well you got to break up
really you take your towel out and go
somewhere else but what if sex is like
not the most important thing to him what
if he's in love with her and that's the
only thing sounds like sex is the most
important thing to him true yeah maybe
it is right maybe sex is not the most
important thing to her in which case
it's a mismatch in which case there's
other [ __ ] females out there that you
can join so if everything's good and he
just wants to [ __ ] more than she does he
has to break up with her damn that's so
extreme it sucks but sex is what
arguably the most important thing in a
relationship i mean arguably i don't
think so one or two i don't know i don't
know so it's three no no it depends on
who you [ __ ] are man it depends on
what your relationship is like
you know some people would say
way lower than three some people would
say this [ __ ] the isis guy would
say one
casper the isis ghost would say one i
wonder what she would say casper the
isis ghost you know that's good oh so
mad i said it no that's great good i'm
glad you thought of something funny
great
oh good all right uh well
i'd say try to [ __ ] figure out a way
that it works for you if you have to
masturbate a couple times in the week
try it don't just be like you don't want
to [ __ ] enough i'm out try all the
things because when you if you break up
with her
you might be like later on like oh man
all i wanted was a little bit more sex
and i broke up with that girl i don't
know just try it
and you know what else you can do is
anytime you see like
any sort of romance on tv or in a
magazine or something and you're with
her you could just look at it and then
look at her and be like damn sex is
awesome huh
and then see how she responds and if she
says yeah then be like and then move her
hair out of the way and then just walk
away you know what i mean but foreplay
is everything like prove it yeah four
plays everything okay
you're saying that a lot i know but that
that's because that's what i like nixon
richard nixon richard dixon
all right all right all right
nice
what's up chris and matt before the
pandemic started for me what was simply
a minor porn addiction grew into a
wallet sucking parasite with the growth
of only fans wow
the pandemic really accelerated this
problem for me due to the isolation and
how prone i am to getting addicted to
dopamine chases safarin
over the last two years plus i couldn't
tell you how much i've spent and now i'm
at the point where after my bills are
paid i am door dashing just so i can
spend more money on there
it's a problem i can't seem to get away
from and i constantly wonder how many
guys my age 22 are dealing with this
problem hope to hear your thoughts and
thanks for always reminding me that life
rips
well dude i'll tell you what leave that
up there yeah um i'll tell you what uh
only fans is a
[ __ ]
problem bro what how how bad baby that
chick
she made 50 million dollars last year on
only fans who's bad baby she's this
chick who uh is like this
19 year old [ __ ] girl that is unonly
fan she was that catch me outside girl
oh my god are you serious 50 million
dollars
so only fans is a [ __ ] problem
how does that make it a problem that
makes it sound like a good thing for her
yeah right that means that all these
dudes are [ __ ] putting in the money
that they have to [ __ ] see this and
then a lot of these dudes exist what's
it for it's the person it's the it's the
um the [ __ ] is it personal nature of it
you know what i mean it's not just porn
like i could watch porn and it's just
[ __ ] people [ __ ] and it's cool i
don't have the thought of ooh let me do
only fans because they're just talking
to me so when you say the personal
nature you mean because it's one-on-one
well it's seemingly one-on-one i mean
but you can message each other i guess i
don't know dirty little secret this
might help if he's actually suffering
because he's like making connections
thinking he's making connections yeah i
know for a fact
for a fact
for
a
so that's a fact yeah whatever you're
gonna say it's a fact that
the women not only fans yeah who are
like bombarded with messages from men
who subscribe and pay for videos or
whatever the [ __ ]
hire
people to respond yeah
so and and i know a [ __ ] guy so
you're jerking off she's hired by women
on only fans specifically to respond to
messages that come to her like
hey baby thanks sexy yeah sure i'll do
this whatever and you're talking to a
[ __ ] guy a russian guy no a guy i
know he's not russian well if he's doing
it some russian guy's doing it and then
you're jerking off to a russian guy why
did you make it russian well because
it's a little bit [ __ ] weirder if you
think you're talking to this [ __ ] 20
year old chick oh and in reality you're
not just talking to one of matalia's
friend you're talking about to some
russian guy that's just like yeah that
is right let me suck your [ __ ] how crazy
i like to use lots of spit yeah you know
what i mean and the guy's just like yeah
yeah yeah yeah
i mean why is he beavis but yeah
but so uh and yeah and ali as
liaison is one of those guys so you
might be talking to me you might be
talking but oh i would love to have that
job dude i would love to make dudes
horny on only fans oh what i would do it
all day i would do talk about addiction
dude i'd do it all day long what would
you write oh dude i would be so coy
forget it in the beginning i would play
hard to get okay i would have played
great dude it would be like my golden
eye i would have so much fun doing it
look give me an example oh nothing just
lounging in an old football jersey
do you know what i mean okay that would
be the beginning dude that would be like
the select your character odd job so how
about when it's like down the road and
like you're really getting a lot of
money to make like dildo videos you know
am i on my knees i'm underground oh yeah
dude that's me i'm underground no one
wants that though
no that's not true why are you
underground like a necrophiliac no like
i'm so low below you i'm subservient oh
yeah exactly okay yeah yeah [ __ ] yeah
dude
yeah weird [ __ ] dude oh yeah you're
there not only would i call you the king
i would literally call you like
lebron oh yeah you're the you're the
goat that would be me i'm underground
and you're the goat bro
bro it's slippery you give it away yeah
yeah yeah yeah you need a proofreader
just getting my four shots of espresso
in an old football jersey wait a minute
is this crystalia no no no
wait i have a real thing now
we're talking about i'm dying and
we're talking about an addict here right
yeah this is an addiction for sure 100
so you're addicted i don't know if
there's he said he's addicted to
dopamine chases yeah well if you know
that then maybe actually there's like
groups for this there's actual therapy
for this kind of [ __ ] if you really want
to stop that might be the only way
because clearly you're aware of your
problem and you ain't [ __ ] stopping
is it affecting your life is it
affecting your uh relationships is it
affecting your income it is affecting
all of these things yes you're only 22.
it started with a minor porn addiction
and the pandemic wasn't nice to anyone
unless you already had a billion dollars
so yeah so this guy is struggling and it
is a real struggle yeah clearly you have
an addiction and also if you're using
doordash
i mean
no he get help you know what he's saying
he's he's working as a door down sure oh
yeah got it yeah yeah oh
just to make ends meet so you're not
even working for postmates you're
working for door dabs it's not even a
postman get help dude if you have
anything to do with door dash get help i
ordered
you don't use postmates or uber you do
if something's not on postmates and then
it's on doordash and you get it yeah
what's on doordad yo what are you
getting like chalupas and [ __ ] from taco
bell cafe de leche
what's that it's a [ __ ] place you
asked me where i get it from that's
where i get it from yeah but what is it
fast food no it's a coffee shop
do they
what are you getting [ __ ] hungry no
no i want coffee it's just a place that
i ordered from dodats that isn't on
postmates does have a good coffee it has
a good coffee doordash they show up and
they just like throw the [ __ ] at your
door though is it smashed when you get
it oh
they do dude this guy [ __ ] stop being
shitty on doordash basically my advice
to this guy is okay don't be shitty when
you deliver your food because doordash
sucks and you [ __ ] terrible what
happened to you on doordash you've got
something going on
sometimes that happened honestly
nah it's just
i think this guy's got a real problem
and you need to [ __ ] get it get your
life fixed but also here's the deal dude
um cut up your credit cards hide your
credit cards um
you know you're not talking to anybody
but some russian dudes really most of
the time
haha you jerked off to russian guys
well but he did though probably at least
once
so no he didn't jerk off to russian guys
he probably thinks he's talking to some
woman and
it's not a woman you think you have a
person
if you think you have a personal
relationship with someone and only fans
i'll tell you right [ __ ] now you
do
not okay at all you do not it's some
[ __ ] guy or some woman who doesn't
give a [ __ ] [ __ ] about you you're
she's money to her but that's kind of
some guys like that like you don't care
about me nice splurt
you jerked off to to me tree
okay there are guys on on on only fans
too right
i'm getting ideas yeah oh dude i saw an
only fans guy once swear to god
we signed up for it as a joke okay not
not gay we're not gay okay it's fine but
it's confined to matter if you are we
did it as a joke because we really liked
this guy on instagram and he was [ __ ]
so ironically funny like we were just
laughing at this guy he was like sign up
for my only fans and we signed up for
his only fans dude and he [ __ ] jerked
off
naked in the kitchen and just came on
the floor on the linoleum dude and he
was [ __ ]
i mean
he was beating it so hard dude and it
was so funny because he was like
and dude he was straightening his legs
like obviously he couldn't he couldn't
bust unless his legs were really
straight and his quads were [ __ ]
tight and dude he was trying to tighten
his quads dude and he finally came and
he almost passed out and we were
dying dude and when you say we
me and the homies and dude um yeah yeah
i didn't know if you meant you and
kristen yeah yeah are you a cow
oh god terrible
me and mommy
so all you did was subscribe is only
fans watch them jerk off on the kitchen
floor we're watching guys jerk off in
the kitchen like every day
me and my homies
we're watching guys tighten their quads
um
what did you say i just really said
anything to watch
your cough on the linoleum was that all
you watched them do yeah that was and i
think there was one other one that we
watched but we didn't watch because we
were already we we busted a nut so oh
okay yeah when it's over it's over okay
me and my
home he's though
nade dog that well that is an eight dog
oh well there you go my homies one of
the only rappers i know yeah he's not a
rapper's singer racist so um all right
let's do another
one hey matt and chris what's up it's
grace from michigan hi grace what up
getting your advice on a question for
kind of both my husband and i
um
we have been together since high school
i'm now 23 he's 25. we've been married
for two years
and our parents are constantly asking us
we need to have kids
get some grandkids and
you know my husband i just like
vacationing we like having time for him
and i we really enjoy this time that
we can have just the two of us and all
of our friends have kids so it's
constantly a thing to like you know
should we have kids that are around
their kids age
should we worry about that and um yeah
just want your opinion i know chris you
have a beautiful
baby boy and man i'm sure that you'd be
a great father one day if it's in your
future
and um yeah you know my husband and i
have been fans of you guys for a while
we've been ride or dies for chris
through everything
support you through everything i'm an er
nurse so i've been through
a lot and my husband's a therapist so he
we both have pretty heavy jobs and we
just appreciate all the laughs that you
guys give us whether it's this podcast
congratulations or king and staying in
the wing
uh yeah so just get back with that if
you're good with that and love to hear
your advice
thanks guys
sounds like you're wearing a ghost so
you go first sweet heart
sweetheart and here's the deal
uh first of all we sh this is adorable
because she [ __ ] sent something in
the king and this thing in the wing and
we just covered it
yesterday which comes out she's a little
bit she's famous yeah she's [ __ ]
she's she's a star circle famous so she
uh she did she did and i was like
telling them one thing and they were
like i can't remember what the [ __ ]
we we butt heads on something the guys
and i but
now i'm glad she's asked it on life
lifeline okay because i want to hear
what you have to say was this the
question she asked on that the same
question oh really i was like i know
this chick how do i know her and then i
my heart started beating i thought uh-oh
and then i realized oh no it's just from
kicking this thing in the wind right
okay and so
um because she had her er [ __ ] on okay
and it was in the car okay and i was
like oh okay so
i think here's the d you want to go go
ahead no i think that dude you this is
the main problem
people whether it be your mom or your
dad or whoever their friends dude it's
so annoying everybody wants you
to go to the next step yes dude let me
live [ __ ] yes let me live now
this is where honestly and i know you
don't like this but the spin move would
work in spades dude okay so give me when
are you having kids
i am one spin out
dude she's also 23 yeah
[ __ ] live in the moment dude every time
you do something it's not good enough
somebody comes up well when you're gonna
have kids yeah boom you have a kid
you're happy now oh when you're going to
have another one yeah my brother or
sister you're happy now you got two kids
oh
the question just you know what shoot
right to the question you really want to
ask when are you dying yeah right
yeah shoot
right to it dude yeah when someone asks
you hey when are you having a kid go
like this i'll probably leave it to be
95 and that's when i'll die right yeah
cause that's what you're really asking
cut to the chase let me live
[ __ ] yeah i mean i completely
[ __ ] agree i think that
uh
it depends on your relationship with
with your parents but just generally i
think it should go something like this
like ask me
say when are you when matt what do you
think you're gonna have matt when do you
guys whenever the [ __ ]
i want so aggressive that's it though
that's shitty you know why that's why
they won't ask again
right right that is true because they're
not gonna stop asking they're gonna be
sideways about it they're gonna be this
gonna be that if you come down hard that
one [ __ ] time they won't do it again
that is
such a [ __ ] stupid question for what
is it
1824
it's not 200 [ __ ] years ago right
it's 20 22.
[ __ ] she's 23 years old yeah yeah
spin move mentality your parents need to
[ __ ] relax what are they quakers i
can't remember maybe they are i can't
remember if it was uh she did look like
she could have parents that would be
quakers honestly yeah maybe but um
maybe i think that uh
i think that possibly
was she talking about only her parents
doing it or everyone doing it
i thought she said just your parents i
thought that too but maybe not but
honestly everyone does it and it's just
annoying dude parents friends do it it's
annoying to do that to someone who's 33
23 dude or just tell them you're not
gonna have kids hey look i'm not having
kids and if one pops out great no i'm
not gonna have
you know what you could actually you
pushed it back you push it back along
yeah if you ask me again never
that's the that's the best that is the
best [ __ ] answer if you ask me again
never and i want kids so if you ask me
again you ruined my life thanks a
lot that's a good one that's that's yeah
that's it
oh [ __ ] dude that's awesome that's
that's
that's the that's the end and then if
they ask again go like this thanks for
ruining my life
[Music]
yeah i mean that's something [ __ ]
nelly out of the [ __ ] thing thanks
for removing my life
[Music]
you thought of that because it's hot as
[ __ ] in here it is hot but you're the
one who keeps coming up wearing velour
don't don't
no but i i
i think though
that's so stupid to say it like
you could do that to your parents too
just don't don't but uh [ __ ] forgot i
was gonna [ __ ] oh also dude when she
started the video it made it sound like
she's like guilty about like enjoying
her life and wanting to travel and [ __ ]
that dude wow you're gonna have whenever
you have kids from that point forward
you're never not gonna have kids enjoy
your life take as long as you want
you're 23 take 10 15 [ __ ] years if
you want to well the womb gets crusty
but okay no
10 15 20 [ __ ] years people having
babies in their late 40s now
[ __ ] your parents [ __ ] her parents well
deep deeper
don't forget the womb gets crusty okay
[ __ ]
your parents the deeper all right so
you want to do how many more do we have
set it so fast
one or two oh only has one and then he
said one or two to make us feel okay
about it he's safer but it's panicking
for him oh sweating so hard he's gonna
get it let's get it let's get it let's
get it [ __ ] little pump
you and then also a little pump this
girl okay guys uh my name is channing
my boyfriend and i are both true babies
hell yeah dude huge fans of both you oh
um
so
we're both gonna be going to therapy
soon um not together just separately
good and i've always appreciated the
fact that both of you are very open
about
going to therapy and seeking help
um it's not a thing a lot of you know
young men do i guess that's right now so
i'm just wondering if you have any words
of wisdom or
helpful advice for
people just taking that leap and
starting to go in that direction all
right love you guys bye
i kind of do i think there's there's one
thing that i i think i think when you go
to therapy it's a common thing to be
like
i'm not going to be defensive i'm going
to like i'm going to like go along with
it and like be open to the [ __ ] and
whatever the [ __ ] and be like if they
say something that i don't agree with
i'm like think about it and listen and
like
sometimes
you you know you better than your new
therapist okay so sometimes it's okay to
be like no no no so let me stop you
there
[ __ ] no
you're just wrong about me
and that i think people have like a at
least i did i had like a hesitation at
first when i started doing therapy about
like
giving them a long leash but dude you're
there on your dime that person also
works for you and i don't mean that in
like a customer is always the right way
you're not always right especially in
therapy
but i do think that like at least for me
again speaking only for myself i did
kind of
overdo the like i'm gonna be like open
and like listen to what this therapist
is cause they're such an expert and i'm
just this [ __ ] with tons of
problems right which is true don't get
me [ __ ] wrong but at a certain point
you can be like
ah
no
just [ __ ] no and i'm not being
defensive but you're wrong
okay do you say you're wrong to your
therapist a lot have you said you're
wrong to therapists a lot well no that's
you just say like i know i don't think
like yeah like nah i mean i know what
you're saying but like i i that's really
not where i'm coming from yeah and what
would your therapist say
she go she'd just go like this
no she would just she just says okay oh
i mean like well that's good she says
okay i don't know what she's thinking
right right she goes like this okay
all right i mean you know it could be
that in her mind but to her credit she
at least acts like she hears me and
believes me you know yeah um
well i guess she's asking if um
therapy is a good thing uh and it i i i
don't you know i don't really understand
the clear questions
she's saying do you have any
she's clearly having a little bit of
trepidation yeah yeah about starting
therapy do you have any general advice
which is exactly what she asked so i
don't know why okay so that's right for
general advice and not specific advice
my [ __ ] is more i give specific advice
because
give specific advice you're a [ __ ]
experience about [ __ ] therapy so okay
so um first of all there's a lot of bad
therapists out there yes that see yeah
do you know why there's a lot of bad
everything at every job out there so
true yeah i mean think about how many
[ __ ] bad
really the only job where everybody is
pretty good is sports player yeah
because it's a true meritocracy right
meritocracy true and i know what that
word means what does it mean yeah for
about sports
so it's whoever gets the most merit is
the best well yeah but yes got out of
that one but you don't know what that
means no i do and i do but it's like
when it comes to therapy um you need to
uh
figure out
if you're like me i go to therapist and
i just think okay this is it's a great
therapist like i just go in and i think
that and then it takes me a few weeks
i'm like wait a second i don't know like
i went to one therapy you do need a few
weeks regardless you do need a few weeks
but i went to one therapist that said
[ __ ]
nothing
he actually didn't use his voice pretty
much nothing whoa really almost it was
like dr wall like he just [ __ ] it was
like i was speaking a monologue in a
play
a bad with a bad audience do you think
this was a strategy or yes it was that
it was like a fruity and [ __ ]
freudian yeah yeah it was like a fruity
and floridian yeah uh uh the branch
davidian people say floridian slip
yeah when they're saying it wrong freudi
fraud and slip could be mistaken as a
freudian slip freudian slip freudian
like sigmund [ __ ]
sigmund freud the what's where it comes
from but when you [ __ ] make it a
whole different word you you like gotta
like
flower it up when you're wanting to be
wrong yeah fruity and slipped dying he's
dying freudian slip
freudian slip freudian because his name
is freudian say this word c-h-o
c-h-o-r-c say it again why don't
you draw with it
c-h-o-r-c
chork
you know what i'm spelling right
c-h-a-r-a-r
c-o-a-l
charcoal [ __ ] right
charcoal
people what because people will be like
charcoal okay well you're not talking
about emphasis you're talking about the
actual wrong [ __ ] [ __ ] word let me
try to think about this in a [ __ ]
different way dude okay
whatever dude it's fruity it's
definitely whatever but it's freudian
and so anyway freudian okay so what was
we telling you oh yeah it's a freudian
[ __ ] way to do it is to just [ __ ]
sit back and let the person talk that's
what my other therapist yeah okay yes
that okay
and i'm talking to this guy and i'm
doing it in the [ __ ] freudian way
yeah
for whitian freudian i mean fruity
sounds cooler yeah that's just not the
way it is so anyway i can't say words
just how they would sound cooler because
then no one would understand each other
you knew what i meant
yeah yes got into that one so so
freudian slip so
um
so he was saying [ __ ] like uh
nothing
and i was like and then i went to a new
therapist and i was like he doesn't
really say much he's like yeah that's a
freudian technique and i was like okay
i'm not doing i'm not going to go to him
anymore i didn't go to him anymore so my
point is find ba find out who your
therapist should be first don't just go
to one and then stick with that one
they're not all good most of them are
bad just like everything is unless it
comes to a [ __ ] what meritocracy and
we both know what that means so
uh i i also think the same is true the
other way don't be like i'm gonna shop
around if you find someone you like
you're [ __ ] lucky and don't not trust
that right if you find someone you like
you are lucky and you are you should
[ __ ]
thank your lucky [ __ ] stars that you
got it right the first go because that's
not common last time i saw that guy that
freudian guy that does it yeah uh he had
a huge [ __ ] coffee spill on his shirt
like a huge coffee this guy sucks
dude and i said to him and i was just
talking talking never saying anything in
the middle of session i said you spilled
coffee on your shirt huh and he was like
yes i did
and he was just like i got coffee i got
a little and i spilled it and i didn't
have a change sometimes i have a change
here and i didn't have one so i'm sorry
about that and i was just like
not for me dude yeah really i'm out yeah
you can't see a client with a big coffee
stain on your shirt it's your [ __ ]
barista i know so that's a bad look that
[ __ ] whatever i mean whatever
dude i mean i'm sure he made a lot of
money but he makes a lot of money doing
it yeah but freudian or freudian uh
therapist they also [ __ ] suck dude
really get your [ __ ] updated yeah
i guess so dude i [ __ ] was going to a
lot of therapists i did that one and
then i did another one that was uh bio
what was it [ __ ] that
bio biodome no with polyamory [ __ ]
stephen he was with charlie probably
short charlie sure
it was uh dr wiese
[ __ ] was it called bio
[ __ ] something therapy
feedback or some [ __ ] i don't remember
what it was what did it do like what did
you do he it was for my ocd and he was
like he and it was like uh you have to
he was giving me all sorts of uh
ways to combat my ocd
and one of the ways was have you ever he
was like what about the who cares
technique ooh and i was like what and he
was like so if you don't say if you
don't close the door right your family's
gonna die in a plane crash and i was
like
i'm with you so far speak in my language
and he was like
who cares
[Music]
the worst doctor
swear to god swear to god that's what he
said
and i said what yeah what is it and he
was like i'll take a lesser example say
you
hop over a crack and you think your
mom's back is gonna break and i said
okay and he goes like this
who cares and i was like well my mom's
back would be bro that's a bad thing he
says and then what and then i said
well then she'd be like bed written and
like
pain in pain deep pain and then what i
said and then
and then i don't know i guess it would
last for a few months
and then what i kept doing that i said
then i guess you would have to go to
physical therapy and
get better yeah
and then she would be better right and i
said whoa dude this guy's heartless yeah
bio-heartlessness yeah and i was like oh
okay
and then he was like that's the
silhouette technique and that was about
the last time i saw him but i did see
him for a few weeks um
yeah man and uh but there that is a uh
that is a technique i don't know if it's
the so what technique or if it's the it
might it sounds who cares i can't
remember what oh the who cares
yeah but it was funny as [ __ ] and i i i
it's for the little things that make
sense but your family died of playing
crap yeah it's not not so what dude only
you've ever become a [ __ ] jeff
bridges character extremely heartless
would you right you say who cares
oh my parents and brother died in a
plane crash so that who cares so that is
my that it's mine yeah i gotta get away
bunch of other therapists if that
happens yeah so uh that is um a
therapist that i i stopped seeing so
make sure you get the right therapist
what i'm saying i do think it's great
that you're both going to see therapists
individually yes and not together first
because you've got to figure out what
the [ __ ] root of the [ __ ] is and the
root of the [ __ ] starts with you and for
him the root of the [ __ ] starts with him
so coming together after that would be
great with all the tools that you
learned the therapy i made the biggest
mistake one time i was dating somebody
and i [ __ ] all over the couch
and then i said who cares and then she
had a therapist for many years and we
wanted to go to couples therapy at one
point and we were like let's try going
she was like let's try going to my third
oh and i and i went and i was like all
right this would be great every
[ __ ] goddamn [ __ ]
thing that came up she was right and i
needed to do this or or that or that and
i was like
could you can you at least pretend to
not be honest [ __ ] you know you
know what you know what i would think
that she would i would think she would
air on the other side if she was a good
therapist at least because she'd be like
i want this guy to at least feel safe it
was him and i would i thought that too
but nope at the gate
wow and meanwhile that woman who i was
dating is the craziest person i've ever
met wow so that
therapist sucked
you know
i don't understand well i guess that's
the thing like you
if you're with if you're a crazy person
and you and you think i got into gotta
get into therapy cause you know people
say i should get to the third i gotta
get into therapy you're if you're a
crazy person you're gonna eventually
just weed out all the therapists until
you get one that agrees with you yeah
that's oh damn that's a good point you
know what i'm saying if you're a
terrible person mentally right you're
gonna be like this therapist sucks he
disagrees with me on everything in real
life you're [ __ ] an insane person yes
right yes yes yes yes
this therapist sucks right talking wolf
right you know what i mean and it's like
yeah
so yeah
yeah i'm gonna talk in wolf and i don't
mean that in the indian way right i
wanna talk i mean like an actual yeah
wolf that talks yeah not like oh hello
talking wolf okay well let's ride into
the sunset no one
thought you meant that
i mean everyone native american fan base
that we have everyone knew you meant a
wolf that talks not if your name is runs
with beer and you listen to this podcast
okay they could think oh i know talking
wolf that why is that crazy and then
they get so pissed off and right off
into the sunset and never listen to this
podcast again i don't want to lose that
fan base okay well you're you're losing
it now no way dude i guarantee this
will get us more native americans nope
absolutely not demographic nope
anyway dude whatever okay i i i'm
shooting this before i'm being in
phoenix but i was in phoenix and i had a
great time thanks for coming out guys
and thanks for wearing your merch which
we do that you can get at crystallia.com
how was it how was phoenix just [ __ ]
crazy man a lot of people yeah mm-hmm
some guy stabbed me oh oh you're all
right yeah i'm fine dude it's a day
later i did phoenix yesterday if you're
watching this a guy stabbed me i'm fine
that's how great i am
wow strong guy yep
who cares who cares i stabbed you who
cares um so yeah thanks for watching
also if you're a fan of congratulations
thanks for watching subscribe to
uh this channel and also it helps if you
activate that algorithm right baby so
give advice to the people
on the show that you've seen in this
episode in the comments we'll respond
and highlight the ones that we [ __ ]
agree with or maybe we don't agree with
them and we'll argue with you either way
we're making friends down there aren't
we so send in a video you can handle
this go ahead
uh stand in the video uh link is in the
description below uh or go to
watchlifeline.com
yes
okay thank you very much thanks for
watching thank you
hello
[Music]